because of your contributions to our
women in film charity event you've
unlocked an honest trailer written by
the a guy who wrote that fake Harry
Potter chapter it's like an honest
trailer made out of every other honest
trailer warning and it's gonna be weird
[Music]
from the technology studio which created
classics like the irresponsible
Englishman and the brave little lawyer
and the key grips who worked on small
movies about all the strange Hollywood
choices of legendary director Mike
potions presents the first trailer that
is literally a spy honest trailers
ancestors of the future imagine a female
led superhero movie in a dystopian
society where everyone is always quoting
House everybody lies everybody lies but
only one Jonathan dares to ask who made
that call because light saber
negotiations have guns now hunky
professors have been a new ideas about
Mulan and snake ours are always coming
out of the road featuring Elvis Kyle who
is here to give the most cringe-worthy
performance of all time and everyone
else is just there to watch Margeaux
montage who makes the audience think
about their weirdest cousin you know the
one who loves weed Jon Snow and polite
European robots excuse me this
impressive dog and his terrible son who
are clearly just there to sell iPods the
only cool shot of minerals that no one
will ever forget seriously why are there
more minerals in there and oscar-worthy
performance by the Brooklyn Bridge Amy
puppets original soundtrack that's so
cubed there's definitely lots of magic
can't be dance Holograms and a climax so
epic you will stop worrying about the
helicopters descending on your home of
course the real reason everyone is
seeing this movie the Yoda vs Dennis the
Menace fight sequence which will have
you saying all of our fragile egos are
gonna have sex we're all gonna get laid
but maybe you will not enjoy this
horrible film about the problems of
every lay movie followed by my 40-year
man voiceover love by sarcastic children
and hated by the crying nerd because
sweet Jesus you are in the movie
equivalent of a mind that made a bad
movie so witness the magic of people
yelling exposition and whispering
character names this awesome car chase
will be in the movie and so will the
scene where two characters sit and read
a magazine until finally a strategically
timed tank rolls over a few of the main
villains nicely can someone tell me why
the original shrek is playing on every
TV in this movie so suit on and strapped
up for this underwater tween adventure
that makes the Smurfs look like a
masterpiece
starring lana del toro beetlejuice
Bueller
you better tune out the same shots of
Wolverine sitting on computers over and
over again unlikable Jane Lynch this guy
chasing a car Nazis playing Pokemon snap
sugar man the little guy
tucked grandpa the Millennium Dustin
innuendos that are memes that are also
metaphors
some Ludd well you really shouldn't talk
just do it
mani Canyon as a very sarcastic bug the
smirking baby that goes to hell
this scene ah I'll Chief Master Sergeant
William candy woo it's me and Academy
award-winning actor solemn Philip school
of ripoffs wait where did all the
puberty cops go they're just gone now
okay okay I get it you want to be wet
jeez hey screen junkies click the box
and remember to watch the movie fights
extravaganza benefitting women and film
May 3rd at 3 p.m. Pacific extra-extra
movies are over you the viewer must
crank all my debt by pretending to be
the Angry Birds Oh Christmas Jones oh
Christmas Jones